la liberté d'expression à tout prix
c'était le message qui était venu
partager les journalistes et auteurs
exilés en France autour d'une table
ronde à la Commanderie high en cours
dans le cadre de la Journée
internationale des écrivains persécutés
emprisonnés empêchés
en avant la répression et la censure
subit pour leurs idées dans leur propre
pays ce qui est inspirant c'est surtout
le parcours de ces personnes la
résilience le courage et puis ça permet
aussi de relativiser et peut-être de
mettre en avant la situation française
et de se dire que finalement ici on est
pas si mal Simon sullimani journaliste
kurde a été emprisonné pendant 16 mois
après la tentative de coup d'État en
2016 pour ses oppositions au pouvoir
turc après sa libérations provisoires il
quittait illégalement le pays à la nage
pour atteindre la Grèce il est
aujourd'hui en France et continue
d'exercer pour alerter sur la situation
en Turquie nous avons beaucoup d'amis
journalistes dans la région qui ne peut
pas diff les nouvelles dans dans son
sous ce nom là parce que le gouvernement
toujours menace on prépare ici on
diffuse ici en sécurité enfin en fait
France ça nous donne cette chance de
partager les nouvelles Michael bachirov
auteur de théâtre et dramaturge russe
subissait la censure de ses œuvres en
Russie il faisait face à des menaces et
intimidation des services de police avec
sa femme réalisatrice un de mes
spectacles il était vraiment interdit
par la police parce que la police elle
est venue au spectacle votre spectacle
aux mille notre président notre état
notre société tatata et ça continuait
faire ce spectacle ça devenu dangereux
pour notre équipe la guerre en Ukraine
la poussée à fuir son pays avec sa femme
et son enfant
70 personnes étaient venues assister à
cette table ronde ce qui m'a beaucoup
marqué c'est c'est l'histoire de leur
parcours c'est la manière dont ils se
sont battus pour leurs idées pour leur
liberté et pour venir jusqu'ici moi je
me sens toujours un peu un peu
silencieux par rapport à de tel de tels
parcours en parallèle de cette soirée
ces intervenants mènent des
sensibilisations auprès des jeunes
autour de la liberté d'expression dans
les écoles 50 images